about how long term the type of research
to eat boosting cortisol in order to get you
the sugar you need.
First of all, we're gonna talk about cortisol
and looking at cortisol level
that he was talking about too,
one thing I failed to say about your question
is I think you should measure things.
So if you can measure things,
you can better change things.
So getting a cortisol test done
and if you have breast cancer,
I recommend to do the Dutch test,
the Dutch complete has the cortisol test in it as well.
So if you don't have breast cancer,
you don't have any hormonal driven cancer.
So even with pulmonary cancer or anything like that,
but let's say you have colon cancer
you're not concerned about your hormone levels
and you just want to look at cortisol levels,
you could do the adrenal stress profile.
It's just a salivary test that is gets sent to you,
it's the ZRT lab, you measure it in four different times
during the day, it's the same exact thing you do
within the Dutch test, but you're not doing the,
so it's a little bit less expensive,
but measure cortisol levels.
So do the adrenal stress profile.
You can measure cortisol levels and see if we need to
to make any changes with that or at all.
It's always best to look at that.